peint toute musique que j'aime
elle vient de là vient du blues ray les
mots ne sont pas vraies alors pour
exprimer ce qu'elle pelouse
j'y mets mes joies ici même et peine et
tout ça ça devient blues je le chante
autant que je laime et je le chanterai
au jour
il ya longtemps sur des guitares
thema loire lui donner le jour
pour chanter les peines et les espoirs
nourris
non mais pour chanter dieu
et la mort
[Musique]
la musique vivra
le plus
ça veut dire que je t'aime de gemalto
[Musique]
je pleure mais je chante qu'on aime
c'est la burqa
toute la musique que j'aime
elle vient de là vient tu fous
et dans les moments ne sont jamais les
mêmes pour tous
nous ce qui est bien dans l'aude tu vas
au fond qu'on peut dire n'importe qui
n'importe quoi tout ce qui vous passe
par la tête
ce qu'il vous passez dans lequel il
aurait ainsi fait soirée à gala oui moi
j'ai un gala après
pas les 800 mg aussi on a le même après
sarrio vecta leur mercie victoire merci
j me voir je suis même fm et tout ça ça
devient le glouglou jamais salaires
[Musique]
il restera toujours
il ya longtemps sur des guitares
d'isle-manoire lui donnait le jour pour
chanter les peines les espoirs
pour chanter dieu et puis l'amour
le jeu ça veut dire que je t'aime
mais
travaux je l'avais je chante ton âme
c'est ma prière pour le quarté
[Musique]
messi
que j'aime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
ouais
[Musique]
blues ans j'ai changé
ouais
nous la musique que j'arrête
de la mairie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]